[Música]
bienvenidos a esta edición de
desinformando en el marco de la semana
de la prensa y de los medios en francia
estamos en el liceo paul valéry de parís
y nos acompaña el tau y él es el
profesor de literatura y de educación
sobre medios en este colegio
durante varias semanas estuvimos
acompañando a los estudiantes en sus
clases sobre medios cuál es el objetivo
de esta asignatura
y la educación sobre los medios está
inscrita en los programas educativos
esta clase tiene dos ambiciones
descifrados con los alumnos cómo se
fabrica la información y por supuesto
hablar de noticias falsas pues ellos se
informan principalmente a través de las
redes sociales muy bien pues veamos el
resultado de este trabajo porque estos
estudiantes se convirtieron en todos
unos expertos en verificación de la
información
para los estudiantes las redes sociales
son esenciales en su vida cotidiana en
especial cuando quieren informarse pero
no desconocen que en estas plataformas
circulan rumores y contenidos engañosos
con el curso sobre medios de hélice o
paul valéry vamos a trabajar en
desarrollar buenos reflejos para
distinguir lo falso de lo verdadero
buenos días
por favor unos buenos días a todos soy
periodista de france 24 tenemos un
programa que se llama desinformando en
el que desciframos los rumores y las
imágenes engañosas que circulan en redes
sociales vamos a aprender cómo detectar
estos contenidos quién de ustedes se
informa únicamente a través de redes
sociales
géminis dominique solo calling he podido
ser les mostramos las imágenes
verificadas por nuestra redacción les
preguntamos si han visto recientemente
alguna información sospechosa en redes
sociales
y tú qué pensaste al respecto
a veces algunas cuentas no están
certificadas confianza en ellas igual
[Música]
los alumnos ya tienen buenos reflejos de
cómo verificar la veracidad de la
información para profundizar en el tema
les damos cita la semana siguiente esta
vez vamos a la sala de informática para
aprender a verificar imágenes
cuando uno recibe un vídeo cómo hacer
para saber si esto ya ha circulado antes
en internet algunos de ustedes ya ha
hecho eso
nuestro
dónde
cuando ven informaciones así ustedes se
preguntan de dónde vienen esas imágenes
esto es unas preguntas que te haces y
ahora es hacer la verificación
los estudiantes van a tratar de
verificar este vídeo de una estampida en
un supermercado
este internauta la compartió en twitter
escribiendo bélgica día de promociones
en lidl de molín bake molenbeek es un
barrio de bruselas la mayoría de sus
habitantes son inmigrantes entre los
comentarios se puede leer se comportan
como en sus países pero que muestra
verdaderamente este vídeo los que ya han
usado google imágenes como harían para
ver dónde ha circulado este vídeo en
internet
pero vemos eso hagamos una captura de
pantalla del vídeo
para realizar una búsqueda inversa de
imágenes basta con importar del motor de
búsqueda google imágenes o yandex una
foto o la captura de la foto de un vídeo
busquemos a mex y kennedy
x
[Música]
ah
ahora que ya encontraron el artículo y
les ha parecido difícil
los alumnos encontraron el vídeo
original que no fue grabado en bélgica
sino en argelia en marzo de 2021 durante
una importante escasez de aceite
muy bien lo lograron les queda claro la
bomba de clark no apaguen sus
computadores
ahora vamos a enfocarnos en
informaciones falsas identificadas por
los alumnos
en tick tock y otras redes sociales
aparecen varios vídeos de auto test de
cómic 19 crean positivo con agua
algunos internautas se preguntan si el
cómic 19 puede estar en el agua otros
cuestionan la fiabilidad de estos tests
antes
ahora
qué piensan ustedes de este vídeo
y para eso para el filtro
y qué es lo que te da miedo exactamente
quién puede respondernos para saber si
los auto test son de confianza o sea y
comida en el agua
una parte de la clase va a buscar para
entender en dónde y cuándo circuló este
rumor
[Música]
y los demás van a preparar preguntas
para una entrevista con un virólogo
sí
y social
antes
[Música]
gracias por la entrevista
propusimos a los estudiantes que ellos
mismos presenten el resultado de su
investigación en un episodio de nuestro
programa desinformando los presentadores
estáis listos podéis quitar las
mascarillas porque estamos en exterior
mano y favor se encargan de presentar
timothée no sé nada
anima tu irrite sigue en el texto que
deben decir los presentadores
ratón
[Música]
guardamos todo y vamos con el resto de
la clase
la semana siguiente les mostramos a la
clase el resultado del programa
terminado por los equipos de fonz 24
y apaguen auto test positivo con agua
del grifo necesito una explicación
de videos idea de dónde está
el agua del grifo sale positiva para con
otro ejemplo de la farsa absoluta de
esta crisis fábrica una prueba de
antígenos positiva al agua del grifo al
poder y si la primera cosa muy posible
que está en juego
ante la
demanda
posible
concluyó sexto
mandando test un producto en el mapa
city of water
qué os parece
es que
crees que este trabajo de búsqueda y de
análisis de imágenes fue algo útil
la formación
y
muchas gracias a todos gracias
muchas gracias a los estudiantes de este
curso de noveno grado de liceo pola
balear y esperamos que hayan aprendido a
tener muy buenos reflejos cuando estén
navegando por las redes sociales
recuerden siempre hacerse preguntas
verificar que sean fuentes confiables y
sobre todo para saber un poco más del
contexto de una foto o de un vídeo hacer
una verificación inversa de imágenes
hasta pronto en un nuevo desinformando
[Música]